I don't have much of a script for this
video a few weeks ago I saw a clip of a
Japanese inventor who has been running
his own micro hovercraft laboratory for
years so I asked my local producer in
Japan to get in touch and ask while I'm
in the country can I please meet the
inventor can I see the hovercraft and
maybe have a go flying it so now we've
taken the bullet train to savami City
two hours north of Tokyo and we're going
to meet hideasu Ito at the local sports
center now I do have a little bit of
experience with hovercraft
[Music]
this is one person's homemade vehicle so
uh I'm gonna be careful not to break it
more than 10 years ago I found somewhere
that was selling really cheap leaf
blowers I bought one even though I
really didn't have any use for it then a
few years later I found that someone had
made a hovercraft using a similar leaf
blower so I thought why not make one
myself
at first I was just interested to see if
my hovercraft would actually work but as
time went on I started to come up with
more and more ideas like let's make a
smaller one let's make it electric
powered let's make something that
children can ride on or let's make
something you can ride standing up each
of those Concepts has its own unique
charm that I found as I worked on
bringing each of them to life
hello could you demonstrate could you
show me around thank you
yeah let's start with the basics
I buy common materials like lumber from
home improvement stores I also use
bicycle parts and components from radio
controlled cars and I usually buy those
online
at first everything was handmade but now
I also use a 3D printer and I can also
Source a lot of small specific parts
from China I actively try to use
resources like that
here at the workshop I'm making
hovercraft using just my hands and
simple tools so if someone out there
wants to try and make a hovercraft too
it's definitely possible
haven't steer this button
s
okay
and this
clockwise yeah
up and down
about
1700 okay
you know how drones normally have four
propellers
I thought that if I could mimic that I
might be able to create something
interesting that would mean I'd have to
create a space in the center so the
pilot could straddle it
and I thought that might be a design
that would work well
[Applause]
as difficult as any other hovercraft
I've driven when she's saying something
you have to push the right button and
turn left on the left buttons
[Applause]
all right
how do I get it to go in the direction I
want to not right now but I'm trying I'm
really trying
I uh my camera operator keeps gesturing
out with your followers I'm I'm doing
love it I really am doing something
George
I appreciate that he trust me this time
John I'm not sure
when I posted it on Twitter a while ago
the view count just kept going up I got
a lot of feedback from people who said
they found it interesting but for me
it's just part of my everyday life so
I'm actually a bit baffled as to why
it's got such a reaction
[Music]
thank you
is that okay
that is incredible thank you so much
Model 8 worked fairly well so I got to
work on model nine and I had a really
simple idea what if I just make it half
the size of course I knew before
building it that it'd be unstable but
now that I've actually made it somehow
it works
it's like I've made a cross between a
car and a motorcycle as for the future
well I haven't thought enough about this
plan yet but I want to try and make
hovercrafts that you can wear on your
feet I think that'd be fun